what if you try to just come forward to
the queen and then with the rook to
attack the queen i mean just try to play
in the most aggressive way you can okay
let's jump back in um so queen takes
pawn is a check it looks like this is
bound to be played what else can some do
i think he's going to play this check
you might as well grab a pawn for free
and yes you have to deal with this pin
ivanka mentioned the black queen can
just go back
park herself back where she came from
defending this knight defending this
pawn but uh simon mentioned maybe the
more ambitious option attacking the
white queen and
we're about to see this maybe
this is the current position on the
board before this rook move where does
the white queen go i'm trying to work it
out maybe it goes to g3 here maybe this
is the problem um possibly so i quite
like quite like ivanka's idea just
bringing it back consolidating and
because you've got then that push in the
center later you're keeping a lot of
love ideas alive so yeah dropping the
queen back maybe pushing one of these
pawns later still with this idea in mind
also with the idea of bringing the rook
the whole way down with a nasty check
hitting the white king